ist es endlich gelungen die quelle der
rätselhafte neutrinos zu finden jetzt in
klick zum science fiction ist es
wirklich endlich gelungen die neutrino
herkunft zu klären
neutrinos werden häufig als geister
teilchen bezeichnet warum über neutrinos
weiß waren bis dato noch so gut wie
nichts eine der größten fragen bezüglich
dieser teilchen ist die frage nach der
herkunft woher stammen diese winzigen
elementarteilchen forschern der
universität würzburg ist es jetzt
gelungen diese frage im fachmagazin
nature physics erstmals zu beantworten
das 2012 entdeckte neutrino big bird
stammen demnach von einem basar der bei
dem strahlungsausbruch der galaxie pks b
14 24 strich 418 entstanden ist
das heißt so viel wie blazing quasi
stella optik zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass aus ihm eine hohe emission
anstrahlung hervorgeht ihre beobachtung
richtung fällt immer mit denen des jets
zusammen
jetzt entstehen wenn materie in das
zentrum einer galaxie seinem schwarzen
loch stürzt im zuge dessen entstehen
meist zwei gasströme welche dann jets
genannt werden der strahlungsausbruch
habe sich zur selben zeit und am selben
ort wie die entstehung des neutrinos
eignet und das würde damit die neutrino
quelle darstellen die forscher berechnen
eine gerade mal 5 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese beiden
ereignisse zufällig vonstatten ging
jetzt aber noch mal kurz zurück zu dem
neutrinos wer sich in der schule schon
mal mit dem standardmodell der
elementarteilchen beschäftigen dürfte
der hat von diesen teilchen bestimmt
schon mal gehört neutrinos sind wie in
einer pressemitteilung der universität
würzburg beschrieben wird zitat die
schnellsten leichtesten und kontaktscheu
ssten elementarteilchen weiter heißt es
auch noch dass es erst seit kurzem
überhaupt möglich sei hoch energetische
neutrinos aus dem tiefen des universums
nachzuweisen und obwohl die zahl der
neutrinos die zahl aller atome im
universum bei weitem übersteige würden
sie kaum in wechselwirkung mit normaler
materie stehen der neutrino nachweis
stelle dadurch eine große
wissenschaftliche herausforderung dar
am vierten dezember 2012 allerdings
konnten wissenschaftler des neutrino
observatoriums ice cube am südpol ein
gigantisches kosmisches neutrino finden
als jupp ist ein riesiger würfelförmige
detector im ewigen eis der antarktis mit
einer kantenlänge von einem kilometer
mehr als 5
tausend sensoren sind darin enthalten
gigantisch sind auch die kosmischen
neutrinos die damit aufgespürt werden
kosmische neutrinos sind um einiges
energiereicher als atmosphärische
neutrinos denn sie müssen durch den
kosmos reisen und dabei teilweise ganze
planeten durchqueren das damals
entdeckte kosmische neutrino big bird
und dass es auch heute geht hatte eine
energie von mehr als 2 peter
elektronenvolt
naja genauer gesagt handelt es sich
damit nicht um ein teilchen sondern eher
um ein gigantisches teil
das entdeckten neutrino hatte eine
energie von mehr als zwei meter
elektronenvolt zum vergleich ein
durchschnittliches molekül auf der erde
hat so eine energie von 0.03
elektronenvolt ein foto des roten lichts
rund 2 elektronenvolt bei diesem teil
waren es nicht zwei millionen 30 mehr
während zwei milliarden 30 mehr werden
zwei billionen aber es sind noch einmal
3 02 milliarden elektronenvolt
der ursprung solche energetischer
kosmischer neutrinos wurde 2012 in der
sonne pool sein oder auch schwarzen
löchern in anderen galaxien vermutet
ganz falsch lag mal also vor vier jahren
nicht denn big bird entstand den
neuesten erkenntnissen zufolge bei dem
vorhin beschriebenen blaser ausbruch wie
genau das aus astronomischer sicht
ablief erklärt karl mannheim zitat
blasen in der lage in ihren jets
protonen auf relativistische energien zu
beschleunigen durch wechselwirkungen mit
licht können im zentralgebiet des basars
daraus spionen erzeugt werden
aus dem zerfall der prionen entstehen
dann sowohl gammastrahlen als auch
neutrinos von allen bekannten objekten
in der astrophysik sind nur die basare
imstande den mit ice cube beobachteten
extraterrestrischen fluss von neutrinos
zu erklären zitat ende
prionen sind winzige und sehr kurzlebige
teilchen sie entstehen bei atomkern
kollisionen und können die eben zitiert
beim eigenen zerfall neutrinos erzeugen
wirklich spannend wie wir immer mehr
rätsel der physik aufklärung bzw der
lösung solcher ungeklärten fragen immer
näher kommen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann bewertet es mit einem
daumen nach oben abonniert kostenlos den
kanal und lasst mich mal wissen was ihr
schon so alles über neutrinos erfahren
habt und was eure meinung zu dem
rasanten fortschritt in der wissenschaft
ist
ich bin auf eure kommentare
gespannt ja und warum trage ich heute
fliege die kollegen von zwei jungs aus
bad soden habe ich kennengelernt ich war
so begeistert von diesen fliegen die aus
alten stoffen angefertigt werden das war
wohl mal ein kariertes hemd dass ich
gesagt habe
ja ich trag war so eine fliege den link
zur harry den gibt's unten in der video
beschreibung bis dann bleibt dran